silencieux là là non silence palestino
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir alors vous êtes ici ce soir dans
le cadre de nos émissions bilan de
l'année pour tordre le cou à une rumeur
qui a couru pari tout l'hiver vous
auriez eu une liaison avec François
Hollande
c'est vrai que vous a appelé pour savoir
si c'était vrai
une vie très sage voilà très sage je
suis mariée il s'appelle Jean-Marc
Germain c'est un bel homme voilà
conseillère régional d'Île-de-France
1ère adjointe au maire de Paris et
candidate à la mairie pour 2014
vous pensez qu'une hétérosexuel à la
tête de la mairie les Parisiens sont
prêts je pense
candidate officiel du PL à la mairie de
Paris avec
98,2% des suffrages si ça marche pas à
Paris pour toujours essayer au Gabon
oh mais c'était un vote des militants
alors Bertrand Delanoë vous a adoubé
c'était pas gagné parce que début il
pensait à Dave comme successeur
moi j'aime beaucoup Bertrand de la Noé
parce qu'il laissera le souvenir d'un
mère irréprochable
irréprochable qu'a fait bouger la vie
c'est pas fait attraper non
votre programme vous avez prévu quelque
chose pour le l'immobilier à Paris ouais
j'ai prévu bien sûr le logement ça sera
le sujet numéro un c'est cher n'habiter
Paris nous on a la chance de trouver
assez facilement des logements mais
j'imagine que c'est assez compliqué pour
le commun des mortels une tente Quechua
au canal Saint-Martin c'est une fortune
de trouver une place
délocalisé une fois mort il y en a plein
qui me demandent ça c'est marrant j'ai
une autre idée aussi c'est d'agrandir
les emplacements de parking pour que les
femmes puissent faire plus facilement
des créneaux
moi la première n'est-ce pas
voilà et alors les Vélib' donc il paraît
que 12% des gens qui prennent des
vélibres sont dopés
d'ailleurs on les voit ils font dans les
couloirs de bus et les bus ont peur
voilà et puis à l'Éternel le problème
des crottes de chien parce que c'est
quand même plus simple d'éviter mine en
Afghanistan qui ne grotte de chien à
Paris
[Applaudissements]
mais
je pense qu'il faut faire quelque chose
pour les animaux de compagnie
c'est-à-dire moi j'aimerais bien qu'il y
ait des endroits dans les parcs pour les
chiens pour voilà ça c'est indispensable
non ça c'était un choix qui avait été
fait normal dans toutes les villes
je suis désolé il y aurait des sacs à
crottes ce serait quand même plus
pratique pour tous les mois je suis pas
d'accord avec ça parce que le sac ça
voudrait dire allez-y vous pouvez faire
n'importe quoi au chien ou chien bien
sûr
et pendant qu'on vous tient on trouve
plus de beuh sur Paris en ce moment
c'est vrai alors face à vous dans la
course à la mairie de Paris donc la
droite propose NKM Nathalie
Kosciusko-Morizet elle est à 35% vous à
37 c'est la partie moins positif du
bilan là quand même pour l'instant je
fais la course en tête et je compte bien
continuer jusqu'au bout comme ça vous
avez de la chance
épouvantable c'est qu'on pouvait même
voter pour Grégory Lemarchal quand même
c'était assez drôle Georges Moustaki a
voté
alors on passe maintenant l'interview
formater c'est du sur mesure pour vous
si l'interview Viva Espagne
[Musique]
comment esta Anne Hidalgo approximatif
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qui chante espagnol
qui pense à ce de natalo que jusqu'au
bon anniversaire
moulto automobile ou une tarif
il y a un peu
[Rires]
alie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
Espagne
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu